[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up everyone you just tapped into
bleacher reports draft crash course the
weekly show where we get you ready for
the biggest event of the nfl offseason
i'm the lead nfl draft analyst here at
bleacher report connor rogers and
joining me once again he's not going
anywhere college football analyst from
stadium michael felder felder how we
feeling we are back at it again today to
go over the running back class
man i'm feeling good like listen we for
those that don't know we had a massive
list of running backs that we wanted to
talk about we're going to get to as many
as we can but this is a really fun
running back class even without a
leonard fournette or a todd gurley type
player
yeah i think you and i were up to about
25 26 running backs in this class that
we wanted to go through we think get
drafted or could get drafted we'll see
how high we get how far we get today but
before we get to the names you got to
know the teams now i think running
back's a position that every single team
in the nfl can take one every single
year but those five that you see right
down on there on the lower the texans
falcons dolphins cardinals and bucks
it's safe to say they need a workhorse
right whether they're losing someone to
free agency whether they just got tired
legs those teams need an absolute
workhorse back and i do think they exist
in this class but felder what i want to
start with uh here do you think there's
a round one guy i think that's the
question we have every year can any
runner running back sneak into round one
or do you think this year they're gonna
be waiting to hear their name called on
day two
yeah i think it's a question of sneakage
right like that's the real the real i
don't know if that's a real word but i
think that's what it is
depending on how the quarterback
situation plays out depending on how the
defensive tackle situation plays out
there might be a running back that kind
of sneaks into that back end and and the
reality of it is is where do we put
these guys against someone like i know
you're going to mention jk dobbins like
where did we put this group of guys
compared to some of those guys that
we've seen end up in round two because
again no girly there's no fournette
there's no adrian peterson there's no
saquon barkley so where do these guys
fit when you slot them from when you
when you slot them at a vacuum
versus slotting them in this actual
draft
yeah it could be like two years ago
right where we saw talented names
deandre swift jk dobbins jonathan taylor
uh one of the young faces of the league
right now have to wait till round two
but a guy like clyde edwards delay are
snuck into the end of round one just
because the team wants the fifth year
option uh on the table so let's waste no
time let's get into the front end guys
the top tier guys and i think that
conversation starts with kenneth walker
the breakout player of this season in
the college football landscape whether
it was the production whether it's the
film i mean he just had a
tremendous year here felder after being
a transfer so i don't want to say a
little bit of a surprise but let's be
honest this was a name that was not
considered a top five draft eligible
running back going into the season and
now he could be the first one off the
board what do you see in kenneth walker
i there's there's a couple things one
getting out of white forest helped him
tremendously because he was still a
touchdown machine at wake but getting
the ball further in the backfield not
playing that slow zone read that they
play allowed him to use what he what i
think is his best trait which is his
vision his vision leads to his
suddenness and the the suddenness his
ability to make an immediate decision
and go with it is his best trait i think
that's the reason why he's probably
going to be the first guy off the board
he's incredibly sudden he's incredibly
quick he makes a decision he sticks with
it and then
he has that lower half strength he has
the ability to run through arm tackles
all those things lead to it but it
starts with if you can get him the ball
deeper in the backfield so that he can
make the decision for himself verse
letting him walk up to the line and then
letting the quarterback read that's
where his value comes from this isn't a
guy i don't want him in an rpo system i
don't want him to i don't want him doing
that what i want him to do is get the
ball deep and then go
yeah north south we know we could do it
that lower leg drive with that body type
all right moving on to my favorite
running back in the entire class and
that's bruce hall who has done this for
a couple seasons now he's just been a
phenomenal felder whether it is the uh
strong body type the ability to change
direction the ability to have the burst
to get out wide but also run downhill
and you see it right there as he carries
defenders for about 20 yards he's got
the power he's got the burst he's got
some shake i think the breakaway speed
with most of these guys is gonna be the
question a lot of them just don't have
that breakaway speed but when you look
at brees hall i think there's still a
lot more on the table there as a pass
catcher yes he has to improve as a pass
blocker but as a pure runner and a
weapon with the ball in his hands i
think he's the best one of this group so
it's going to be interesting felder
kenneth walker breese hall i think they
can come in and handle those workhorse
rolls we were talking about earlier in
the show and i think they can come in
and do it right away
yeah i'm a walker over breeze guy but i
think bruce is really really good i
think he i think brees is probably
and it's crazy to say this i think he
has the ability to hit more home runs at
the next level even though what we've
seen from kenneth walker are a lot of
home runs including the play where he
high-fives his teammate against the
rutgers so i think the big key for me is
going to be with brees is what does he
look like on third downs you see a guy
you can have in the field on the field
on third downs this is something that i
think about all the time and when i'm
watching college football when i'm
charting plays i like to see who's in
the game on third down and what they're
doing and i thought about it with travis
atn a year ago two years ago because he
was the guy they had to either take off
the field or they had to have him in the
pattern and i think bruce hall is going
to be interesting at the next level
especially when you talk about complex
blitzes you talk about linebackers green
dogging what does this look like so i
love him i love the way that he runs i
love his running style i think he's a
weaver very similar to travis etienne uh
he's not a a juke you guy he's more of
like weaving in and out finding his
space but i think he's a really good
player i just i think walker has more
ability to pass pro and both of these
guys can hit home runs so give me the
pass program
yeah i think that conversation carries
over to our next guy and isaiah spiller
who you know is a little different than
those guys but the questions around
passpro
is going to be a big one because on for
me the film i see the effort there but i
think the he struggles to identify
things pre-snap so when you just break
him down as a pure runner insanely
patient he's got the big frame he's got
the light feet to make you miss in the
back field pff had him charted with 56
missed tackles forced in 2021 that means
he is creating his own yards and that is
something that always carries over at
the next level for the nfl i think he's
excellent at navigating that line of
scrimmage traffic where it looks like it
could be a tackle for a loss and then he
could turn it into six yards and that's
a skill that is so important at the next
level where let's be real the defensive
line they're gonna be in your face
sometimes as soon as you touch the
football so spiller it's really
interesting i think you and i agree
walker and bruce hall looks like they'll
be the first two off the board but it's
going to be interesting to see how
spiller stacks up and how long he has to
wait because he has some of those skills
that they carry as well
yeah he can be a home run hitter he can
also be a guy like i
watching todd gurley at georgia isaiah
spiller has a lot of those things that
remind me of that and it's not the size
type thing but it is that track level
like light feet speed that you have he
does the little duck up and down duck up
and down when he runs and it's the
making someone miss in the backfield and
i think that's the part where
hey man
our offensive line isn't where we want
him to be yet
but he's also not going to be
saquon barkley he's not gonna be
um barry sanders where you have these
negatives negatives negatives negatives
big he's always a positive guy and i
think being always a positive guy goes a
long way and i don't think i'll have
enough people realize being always a
positive not creating negative plays for
your team puts you in a position to
where you can convert third downs and
that is humongous for sustaining drives
yeah it's massive i think on you know
purely as a runner that style reminded
me of le'veon bell a little bit with the
body type the patience the ability to
make you miss in the backfield he's not
there as a pass catcher or a pass
protector le'veon was on a different
level in those areas but our last top
tier running back here this is someone
that he does not have these size maybe
as those last three guys but he's got
the three down ability and he takes a
lot of pride in it it's kyron williams
from notre dame i think with kyron
felder he comes into camp and coaches
just love that they trust him right they
know on third down he takes pr pride and
pass pro he's got the contact balance
he's a little bit more of a compact
runner you could lose him in the
backfield he's got the strong lower half
even at that size he's about five nines
you're talking about a totally different
style of runner than the last three we
saw and maybe doesn't possess that elite
top gear breakaway speed but in that
zero to 12 yard area he just finds ways
to get it done felder i love kyron
williams he feels like the value of the
running back class because he just never
has to leave the field he can handle any
role that you ask of him right away
i i love him too and i the thing i like
about him and we're watching the clips
now
he's not he he likes living between the
tactics
he's happy with him he likes living
between the tackles that's that's a safe
place for him and for most running backs
that's a dangerous spot and they want to
get outside and get wide and find green
and look for space he likes living in
that space and i think that's a really
positive thing for him i i mean the guy
is he is short but he is not small and
we saw it with what clyde edwards
hilaire right like a guy that's short
but not small and i think that fits i
think obviously him
gaining more in the past catching game
is going to be important but for him he
is someone that doesn't want to bounce
he wants to stay inside and i think that
staying inside is a huge benefit to what
he's able to do
all right let's take a look at the
comments right now the first one here is
from chief garza who said who would you
rather have as your third down back
kyron williams or tyler beatty an
interesting debate there felder
obviously beatty had a monster year both
as a runner and a pass catcher
i would lean kyron williams just from
what he's done in pass bro over the long
haul and how much i value that but i
think this is a tough one
i mean it's tough baby's good man i mean
the numbers he put up for mizzou like
that's wild it's time you know what i'm
going to go opposite of you i'm going to
go with beatty
listen i know that he did we know this
from behind the stage he didn't quite
make the cut for the all the clips that
we have so i got to give him a little
bit of shine i'm going to go with him
and the reality of it is is i mean
he's not as good at pass pro as kyron
but i do think he's a better pass
catcher which gives me a safety valve
for my guy to kick the ball out to
all right another i love this question
by the way from mbr 12 what do you think
of pierre strong jr out of south dakota
state think he's one of the bigger
sleepers in this class i am with you mbr
when you look at pierre strong might not
be getting the love as these top guys
shrine game invite small school felder i
think he's had a thousand yards at least
the last three seasons so definitely on
our sleepers list listen we can't get to
a mall here we're gonna try our best
felder
yeah he's super productive i mean we
gotta put sincere mccormick in that mix
too right like someone that's also
coming from a school that a lot of folks
aren't talking about but i think he also
is gonna be productive at the next level
so both of these guys are someone that
you have to think about when you're
going into this mix because
running backs can come from anywhere
who's my guy that play for the bears
from north carolina a t a little short
power play
now i can't remember
you got it tariq cohen
there we go and like they running backs
come from everywhere everybody can come
from everywhere but running back
specifically it's a group that if you
have the vision you have the speed and
you've got the strength to go with it
you've got an opportunity to play so i
think both of those guys they belong on
the list for sure
and it goes back to our opening
conversation in the show of why there
might not be a first round running back
because teams think they can get them
later on let's keep this moving we did
top tier we had four guys now we're
looking at the workhorse running backs
and man felder when we prepare for the
show you are so jacked up to talk about
this first guy brian robinson jr from
alabama felder please take the floor
right now
i love this guy he is
he's the epitome of a teammate he's what
you want on your football team you ask
him he'll do it and you see him there
this is against ole miss and here's the
thing the ole miss game nick saban was
upset nick saban said guess what we're
gonna run the ball a bunch you see him
here catching the football against
mississippi state and then taking it to
the house
he does whatever you want he's someone
who's had 30 carries in a game he's also
someone who's caught like six or seven
balls in a game you see him there
bossing up and trying to run somebody
over he does anything and i love that
about him he is someone he reminds me a
little bit of um a bigger version of was
it steven ridley right from lsu that
played for the pax for a little while
yup he reminds me of him as someone
who's just going to do
his job
and i can tell you something having
friends that played in the nfl being
around football for almost basically my
whole life now
if you do your job they keep asking you
to come back and they keep giving you a
paycheck
yeah i think there's something to say
about brian robinson sticking it out at
alabama waiting his turn and then taking
advantage of that this year where he
looked great as a workhorse runner he's
got the power he's got the body type uh
down at the senior bowl he took a lot of
pride in pass pro in one-on-ones and i
think coaches eat that up we know he's
got the body type to do it but when you
actually put the pads on and show it
he's going to be one of the best value
picks of this draft because of how
versatile he is and that powerful frame
that he carries all right our second
workhorse back on the list i think this
is a name that a lot of people are not
familiar with yet it is ronnie rivers
from fresno i think when you watch the
tape
he kind of reminded me a little bit at
times of a lightning bug you can lose
him there in the backfield he's got a
lot of shake he's got a lot of jitter uh
he really made a ton of guys miss and i
saw some burst at the second level that
surprised me we know the workload has
been there yes they used two running
backs in this offense but he made the
most of his carries i love what i saw
and you see the pass catching right
there the ability to split the two
defenders the burst is what stands out
to me
i'm excited about where he goes because
he didn't get that senior bowling by he
didn't get a lot of love throughout the
season but he did get the shrine game
invite now i think at the combine he can
make the most of it he might be the most
uh underrated or least talked about
potential starting running back in this
class
yeah i agree with you there's a
suddenness to his game that i really
enjoy we talked about that with kenneth
walker obviously you see the fight there
to get to the end zone but he reminds me
like that reminds me i love the fact
that he played for jeff tedford
and so he had to do all the stuff you
wanted nfl running back to do and i
don't think enough folks
look at coaching staffs and look at what
guys are asked to do
because there's a humongous thing in
college football where
coaches only ask you to do what they
want you to do and they only ask you to
do what you can do and so what i look at
a lot of times is what they don't let
you do and for a lot of these running
backs they didn't let them catch the
football and that was either a
reflection of the quarterback or
reflection of the offense or reflection
of that running back ronnie rivers was
asked to do everything and he did pass
pro he caught the ball out of the
backfield he ran routes down the field
he ran routes he ran rounds horizontally
across the field uh they have total
faith in his ability to do everything
you want a running back to do i think
it's good that you hit on burst i do not
think that his top end speed is elite
but i do think that he has a quick burst
very similar to another guy that we
already mentioned since sir mccormick
he's got a good burst that burst allows
him to get away and listen when he gets
those little getaway sticks going
he can he can move make you miss and yes
you might catch him but he's gonna pick
up an extra 15 yards
all right let's move to our next
category this is bruisers i think this
is some of uh the favorite film of the
fans the truck stick and we got two
right here i'll start with the first one
probably my favorite you know sleeper in
this class those days are gone damien
pierce from florida when you look at him
he's a david montgomery clone to me with
that power yes the lack of usage at
florida was a bit perplexing but
pierce's power his ability to drive his
legs
and i do think there is a
very underrated change of
directionability in his game for
somebody that carries 220 pounds of pure
power where you see him move his feet
and get outside and cut back inside but
he does not have the fear to lower the
shoulder and take on not just dbs but
linebackers i think he sees red down at
the red zone felder where he knows i
need this touchdown i will do whatever
it takes to get in the end zone you saw
the stiff arm there so if you're looking
for a david montgomery clone he's a top
five running back in this class for me i
had him right at rb5 in this class i
cannot wait to see what damian pierce
does at the nfl level
i know we got to be quick so i want to
just i i agree with everything you're
saying so i wanted to ask
him at the senior bowl with the way that
he was aggressive in pass pro
do you think that's the biggest
motivator for him being pushed up in
this draft
i think so because when you look at all
these guys it's easy to lump them
together and say we can put him on the
field on first down second down that's
fine but what do we do on third down or
what if our third down back gets hurt
can you do both you said at the top of
the show felder find you someone that
can do both if you can find someone that
could be the early down bruiser the goal
line back but oh wait on third down we
don't even notice he's on the field in a
good way
it means a lot it means so much in the
nfl every running back coach in the
league will tell you you got to check
two of three boxes to play in the league
you got to be a good runner you got to
be a good pass catcher or you got to be
a good pass protector you need two of
the three to get drafted he's got at
least two of the three all right our
second bruiser and i saw the comments
jumping for this guy in a fun way jay
doe said tyler algiere most underrated
running back in the draft you don't have
to wait any longer it's time to talk
about tyler algiere felder before i
throw to you he reminds me of richard
mendenhall who ran a 4-4-1 at 225 pounds
i see a lot of that in algier what'd you
think of his film from this year the
last couple of years he played with zach
wilson as well
he's a beast i mean this guy he's a big
he's someone you don't want to tackle
and i think that that's that's one of
those qualities that's kind of one of
those trump cards you keep in your back
pocket of like oh yeah nobody wants to
tackle this guy until you see guys make
business decisions i mean we just saw a
business decision right there i'm not
actually going to get in the way
and i'm not going to get in the way and
i think that's important like you see
guys whether it's them going low or them
grabbing and it's because he's already
punished him look at these missed
tackles these aren't
these are guys making choices you see
the guy come flying into the legs
instead of trying to make an actual
tackle
all like we keep we keep seeing it in
the film connor like what else is there
left ahead
this guy makes pay for it he's a better
running back in the fourth quarter than
he is in the first quarter because of
the work that he puts in and one through
three to get the four
yeah i think when you're looking for
someone to close out games this is the
kind of player you want where you're
playing with the lead it's the end of
the third quarter we're gonna go at
least run run pass some teams will go
run run run and it might be algier three
times in a row so let's take a break to
go to the comments quick before we move
on to the home run hitters i know that's
everyone's favorite part
man i loved one right here because we
didn't touch on this too much yet rhys
helming 27 says who would be the best
pass catcher among the running backs
this year i know we got two later that i
don't want to spoil but felder you've
been teasing sincere mccormick who's not
amongst the group we're going to talk
about later so let's use this time to
talk about him he reminds me of devin
singletary a lot with that short area
the ability to catch the ball as well
you've seen a ton of this team break it
down on sincere mccormick
conference usa to conference usa i love
it my man no he
said mccormick is so good he is a guy
that he catches the ball out of the
backfield and i love his ability to
he has that same burst that we've been
talking about where
once he gets the ball in his hands it's
like he gets a little like a super mario
shot of energy where he can just go go
go go go go and yes if you're faster
than him you're going to catch him but
you're going to catch him 30 yards
downfield and i think that his ability
to catch out of the backfield his
ability to
be a piece that you are worried about
running because he does like to run
between the tackles i love the his
he believes in the idea of the fastest
the the quickest distance between two
points is a straight line
and so he's not looking to bounce
everything he goes straight when he
catches the ball he turns straight up
field and i think that that is
jarring to defensive backs at times
because you're taught so often to
protect the sideline and to use the
sideline as another defender but guess
what when the guy doesn't want to go to
the sideline now you're like oh no it's
just me and him in
all this green i'm in trouble because
he's got great leg drive
and after the catch for me whether it's
one of those angle routes or it's him
running a little snag thing him flaring
out all those things he has the ability
to
turn every single one of those plays
into a big play so yeah [ __ ] mccormick
i think he's got an opportunity to be
the best pet especially if he's only in
on third downs as a young player guess
what he's going to block a little bit
then he's going to bounce it out and and
he can do pass pro so he's gonna bounce
it out make a catch let's go make a play
all right i'm gonna throw it at you here
fella from the comments before we move
on to home run hitters pork chopper said
tyler beatty the next aaron jones maybe
that's a little lofty but we got a lot
of baby love on the show what do you
think of the player com comparison from
pork chopper
i dig it i mean aaron how long did aaron
jones play in the league man
he's in there he played for a long time
right
oh yeah and just got aaron jones he's
still killing it for green bay
like that like that's like he's been in
the league for a while like he just
keeps slowly getting it done nobody
mentions him as the top running back of
course and and baity's in that same spot
because nobody mentions him as a top
running back from the sec uh we we got
to baity uh after we got to brian
robinson and we're going to talk about
some other running backs out of the sec
as well but like nobody so he's just
going to guess what
all we we i just said it you do your job
they keep paying your money and he's
gonna that's the guy that he is he's
gonna catch the ball in the backfield
he's gonna work in pass pro and he's
gonna do his job and they'll just keep
giving him money and i think it's
fantastic so i i like baity i think he's
really fun to watch obviously he didn't
play on a great mizzou team this isn't
one of those teams that competed for an
sec championship so this is a team where
a lot of folks weren't watching but if
you did watch mizzou you did recognize
that he was the heart and soul of that
offense
all right felder let's move it along
home run hitters we've been talking
about it for a while and this was
someone you brought to the table early
on said we gotta have him in this
category and it's chianti ingram from
usc this is obviously an offense that
had their own struggles whether it was
the
volatility of the quarterback position
whether it was losing somebody like the
players have lost in the offensive line
over the years like elijah vera tucker
drake london getting hurt but ingram
home run hidden category he had seven
games where he had a run of over 20
yards and some of them were much longer
than that what do you see on ingram in a
class that just does not have a lot of
breakaway speed
well i you see the patience there and
you see like on that run you see the
patience here's another one he he
reminds me a lot of a guy and i know he
didn't have the nfl career that he
probably wanted to have but he reminds
me a lot of lake seastroke
who was a guy who stick his foot in the
ground and then go he's got this stick
my foot in the ground and then i'm gone
and you see it on that run right there
right this one ends up being a great one
right i mean i'm getting there i'm
getting there i'm almost there he's got
to stick your foot in the ground and go
and what do you see when you watch him
because to me like
i guess because i i live in this world
of recruiting and of of college lake c
strong was a really good running back
uh he just didn't have it didn't get it
done at the nfl level i think keonta
ingram could get it done but he had that
stick your foot in the ground one cut
and go running style
i think he is a outside zone darling and
when you look at the teams that have
drafted those guys on day three over the
years whether we talked about aaron
jones in green bay the niners do it
every single year the jets offensive
staff came from the niners so it's the
same with them you could see the rams
start to implement that as well
obviously the browns the vikings dalvin
cook has been hurt a lot as great as he
is alexander madison set for free agency
after next year could be looking for a
backup there if you are an outside zone
team and you're looking for value on day
three ingram's probably gonna be your
guy and i like that you brought up
seastrunk man was he a fantasy community
darling for a long time everybody was
waiting for that big breakout year
that's a throwback name all right second
home run hitter one of my favorite
running backs in this class is jerome
ford everybody knows the story transfers
from alabama to cincinnati legitimate
legitimate top gear breakaway speed now
i think he's more than that i want to
make that clear what your room for it i
saw a lot of ability to run inside to
make somebody miss at the line of
scrimmage or linebackers at the second
level but if you do make that if you
miss him and let him in the second level
with space and you see some power there
too in the lower half he's got this top
gear to break away and make things
happen and the checkdowns that we see so
often in the nfl where he can catch the
ball five yards in the middle of the
field and then get outside away from
linebackers that's gonna be a problem so
felder i love jerome ford and i think he
has something in this class that quite
frankly there maybe isn't any other back
that offers that top gear getaway speed
i think there's one guy that does and
we're going to get to him in a little
bit but i agree with you i i think the
big thing for me with jerome ford is
he's so dangerous he if you in the way
that i think about it as a safety
if your banana route down is wrong if
it's off by a little
it's over it's game over and now you're
chasing someone you'll never catch and
so
he does have not just a burst but he has
high top-end speed if you have burst
plus top-end speed that leads to
touchdowns uh the play that we just saw
against houston where the safety takes a
bad angle and then next thing you know
he's scoring a touchdown where he's 20
yards away from anybody else that's what
he brings to the table i love i love to
watch this guy play and i love that that
fickle was like listen man if you're
going to be in the game for us you are
going to have to run in the interior
you are you're going to have to
and he responded to it and i think he
responded to it in a good way
felder we got a comment right there that
was uh that was from lee schechter
saying would all these belichick isms i
have to wear a cut off sleeves hoodie
next week felder is that in the wardrobe
for any crash course episode
i might have to i might have to make one
man what belichickisms am i doing i'm
doing belichick
all right moving on frost uh pass
catching running backs
this is a fun one because he hasn't
gotten too much love out there yet max
borge
felder this is someone who in 2019 he
had 96 targets and dropped only two of
them in 2018 he had 61 targets and
dropped only two of them
borgie is about as reliable as it gets
as a pass catcher what's got you excited
about his game at the next level
dude come on i love him this guy catches
the football he can catch the ball all
frame i don't think folks realize that
last catch we just saw where he had to
turn his body completely around that's
really hard to do wide receivers who
played wide receiver their whole life
can't do that all the time and he's able
to do it as a running back i i love his
vision as a runner he's he is someone
and we talk about guys that like to stay
inside he's someone that does like to
find the corner and that's the part
where i think it's going to be
interesting to see
how desirable folks find him at the next
level because as a running back he likes
to find the corner he likes to find the
edge he likes to be outside likes to
play outside the hashes but as a pass
catcher as and that's the category we're
talking about pass catchers if as a pass
catcher i don't think there's anyone
more reliable than max borge when it
comes to catching the football out of
the backfield
yeah i'm with you there the reliability
is the factor the production is insane
now you nailed it he's played in an
offense where there's been a lot of
space to work with right so
what is your role for him at the next
level when you draft him i think third
string comes in on third downs
eventually and you can really utilize
him as a check down for a young
quarterback that is going to be very
check down friendly
this next guy i think has more than that
and this will wrap up our running back
preview before we move on to the nfc
east divisional breakdown
this feels a little bit of us saving
one of the best for last and it's kind
of crazy how little buzz there's been
about him in the running back class
maybe because of how deep this is but we
put him in past catchers we know he
could do a little bit more than that
felder it's james cook from georgia i
don't know if it's because of being
undersized but when you just look at the
burst you look at the cut back ability
of course the ability to make you miss
after catching the ball creating his own
yards the wide runs you got to be
excited about what you've seen from
james cook and how that translates right
i love him i mean i'm not what do you
want me to do mint's words like i'm not
going to cuss but goodness gracious i
love this guy like he is
he's my favorite if i had to pick one
favorite running back out of this class
it's him
he can do everything i've watched him do
everything
and i think he was underutilized at
georgia
but oh my goodness you want to talk
about a guy and the scariest part is
what is it lmfao like i'm sexy and i
know it like this guy is good and he
knows it
like he is so ready to rock and roll
like
i've seen him line up at wide receiver
this is another guy that i've known
since 2015. seen him line up at wide
receiver against top corners
top corners in the country
and be like
you can't cover me goodbye and then take
off so this is a guy
at the running back spot that you can
line up in the slot you can line them up
on the line you can line them up in the
wing you can light them up in the
backfield you can line them up in that
that deep pistol you can do anything
with them and he's going to make it work
he's remarkable he broke open the game
we talked about jabari sawyer coming in
and helping expose that hole but without
james cook that whole that run doesn't
go for 64 yards against alabama because
this is a guy that has the vision he has
the ability he sees it he is my favorite
running back in this class he is my
favorite like
man he
he is a tremendous thorn in the
defensive coordinator's side because you
don't know where he's going to be i
think he's a plushed up version of
deandre swift and that's not a knock on
swift it's a compliment to james cook
this is someone who
in theory you're in the game and you're
in 10 personnel or 11 personnel one
running back no tight ends one running
back one tight end and then all of a
sudden he motions out now what's your
mic gotta do what's your will gotta do
they gotta go run with james cook
runway where are you going
and we saw it happening against michigan
like you can't do anything with him he's
too good i i don't i'm trying i i am
being effusive because that's how good i
think he is i i think he's remarkable
felder the comments agree with you i
mean the comments are absolutely giving
james cook a lot of love thinks he would
be the steal of the class js bogus said
james cookwood and philly would be a
problem i think he complements really
well with miles sanders that makes a lot
of sense you're talking about a team
with jalen hurts that they are going to
utilize get the ball out and and you're
going to manufacture your yards we're
not going to throw vertically we have
the two tight ends you get james cook in
there as the pass catching running back
and yes i know everybody's wondering it
he is the younger brother of dalvin cook
and you see that short area agility that
dalvin has not surprising in james
cook's game in james cook game but as
felder said man there's just a lot to
like there and the usage is so perfect
for what a lot of teams like to take in
rounds three or four of the draft and
those guys always outperform those
expectations we saw with alvin kamara
just a couple of years ago taking in
round three uh that role could be a
little bit similar so all right let's
get to the comments here and yes they
are going to be angry about the running
backs we didn't mention but as we told
you we have an hour here we had 25 we
had to cut some let's get into the fun
hey johnson 310 says no hassan haskins
y'all sleeping he reminds me of ben
jarvis green ellis or marion barber
marin barber is a fun comparison i think
with haskins right now
it's more of the season was great and
he's going to be a productive nfl runner
now his process has been a little hurt
by being injured he had a senior bowl
invite couldn't participate because of
injury combine i think he's still hurt
right now so with haskins
this comment is right he's been buried
in this group but fell there i don't
think we're sleeping on haskins we know
what he can do probably would have fit
really nicely in the workhorse or
bruiser section of the show right
yeah i would have put him in the
bruisers uh he's someone although let me
i will just say this
when your offensive line is pushing you
forward
that should not count as rushing numbers
so but no i think he would fit into the
bruisers i like him i like him a lot i
think he's a good running back i think
the the key for him is going to be
getting healthy if he can get healthy he
can make things happen it's just about
his health and obviously that's going to
ding him in terms of uh not just the
combine but what happens you know when
we get to the end of the actual nfl
drought
all right the next one is from mbr 12 is
running back forever an undervalued
position going forward in the draft or
could the right talent go early i think
when you look at running back and the
draft you have to get used to kind of
looking in the christian mccaffrey role
or obviously devos samuel was a wide
receiver coming out but to go in the
first round we saw it with naji harris
last year you basically have to be able
to do everything and we saw i know he
got hurt but jacksonville had the same
plan for travis etienne they felt that
he could play slot receiver and he can
also line up in the backfield so i think
we're in the era where if you're a
traditional true running back you're
probably not going to go in the first
round but if you're a unicorn that can
motion out to the slot that can handle
these jet sweeps and also be a
traditional running back in the sense of
running from behind the line of
scrimmage pass protecting past catching
well then you have a chance to go in the
first round so felder i think it's a
matter of i don't know if it's
undervalued because teams are finding
that value on day two but the fact of
how the position ages and how much
talent there is year after year for
whatever reason that's probably why it's
just not going early anymore right
well listen this how long have we had
this conversation when you and i worked
together at br we were having this
conversation right no value no value no
value
here's the reality it's about talent you
mentioned that unicorn complex or having
to be a unicorn
sequon got picked in what top five top
six
because yeah number two there you go
yeah they valued what he could do and so
there's that we we see todd gurley go
early we see
you can go early if you're a running
back if you are
super good
glennar fournette
or
you can do all the little things
christian mccaffrey and
so
i think that it's a conversation that we
just have to reframe how we discuss it
honestly i think that the running back
conversation has laid itself out pretty
clear you have to be super good
and you have to be able to do a lot of
different things
i think it's way it's a way less complex
conversation than safety when we get to
safety that's the conversation that's
more complex with respect to value
because
none of it makes any sense
so yep to me i i think that running
backs we just don't have like come on if
we're looking at these running backs in
this draft and we like a lot of these
guys we like all these guys we're big
fans of them but if we had leonard
fernett if we had todd gurley if we had
christian mccaffrey these guys would all
be pushed way down
and i think that's the reality of the
situation so i think it's just about
being super good and then also being
able to do a lot of different things he
can't be a one-trick pony
and i think part of it is what history
tells us right you look at the top 10
rushers from this year jonathan taylor
second round naji harris first round
we'll give them that joe mixon second
round antonio gibson third round alvin
cook second round alvin kamara third
round
when you go down the list teams are
saying we've built a structure of an
offense with our offensive line with our
scheme from our run game coordinator to
our offensive coordinator
running a ton of 12 personnel obviously
in today's nfl there's so much tight end
usage that you think you can find the
right guy to be one of those top 10
backs without having to spend the
premium asset and allocating it
somewhere else maybe like the trenches
but
great conversation on the running backs
i feel like we got through a pretty good
amount i'm sure there's a
handful we left off you know here but
let's do the recap all right so
we had in the top tier of running backs
kenneth walker bruce hall isaiah spiller
kyron williams and then we moved on to
the workhorse running backs brian
robinson jr from alabama ronnie rivers
from fresno state then you look at the
bruisers damian pierce tyler algiere the
home run hitters keonta ingram and
jerome ford the pass catchers max vorgie
and james cook a felder favorite this is
a pretty loaded group off of the tiers
we also mentioned sincere mccormick
tyler beatty up here strong junior this
is a loaded group folks your team is
going to find the answer at running back
if they strike early or if they strike
late and speaking
go jump in felder
i also like zonovan knight from nz state
a lot
i like him a lot just had to get it in
throw him in
had to get him in there i've been like
oh can i jump in it's like double dutch
waiting for you to finish so i could get
in there but yeah i like zonavid knight
as well i think he's someone that's
going to be very interesting at the next
level all right so let's go what else we
got
all right i'll do the same i'll take
devonta price from fiu i think he can
have a better nfl career than he had
college career all right nfc east
breakdown there's a lot of work to be
done in this division and the giants
know that they just started with their
new regime but we're not going to talk
about just the giants we obviously have
them right there offensive line pass
rusher corner the commanders it's gonna
be about quarterback folks there's no
way around it the eagles got three first
round picks maybe wide receiver again
looking for pass rush help and corner
the cowboys i think they're going to be
looking to beef up both sides of the
trenches whether it's a guard or whether
it's going to be more pass rush help or
maybe interior defensive line so felder
let's start with those new york giants
they hired joe shane as their new
general manager i think he's a guy
coming from buffalo that knows there's a
lot of work to be done from the ground
floor looking at what's in front of the
quarterback looking at the guys that
need to get after the quarterback they
have picks five and seven in the top ten
where are you starting with them for
this draft
they they're in i mean they're kind of
like like a little honey hole right like
five and seven like you can do
you get one get another you can do
whatever you want i'm gonna go with uh i
can't iguana from nc state the tackle i
know you like why am i like you talk
about him this guy's a bruiser we talked
about bruisers at running back he's a i
mean he's a big-bodied force at the
offensive tackle spot that can
bring in some identity to this football
team as they go through this
transition
yeah i think when you look at akwanu
it's just the impact he has on the run
game right there's guys that
might not look out of place and can be a
cog and then there's guys that can
change your run game almost on their own
and you see him just throwing bodies
around uh looking for two right he's not
just trying to get one one guy in the
dirt he's trying to throw two in the
dirt equino's a tone setter and for a
new york giants team that has gotten
bullied in the trenches for a long time
this changes that tone for you so akwanu
everyone's starting to love him right
now you hear the presser at the combine
really interesting guy he was not this
five star or even four star recruit but
the development that he has had at nc
state the game changer he is as a run
blocker uh he's going to hear his name
called early so felder i love that pick
at five i'm gonna throw it to seven they
hired wink martindale from the ravens
the ravens obviously a team that plays a
ton of man coverage and they blitz and
they live and die by the blitz and if
you're going to do that you need man
cover corners i think for the giants
they're going to move on from james
bradbury because of the cap hit so i'm
going to look at sauce gardener here
felder this is your guy right here this
is your top corner in the nfl draft
sauce is somebody that we know he can
play out on an island in man coverage
but his physical nature coming downhill
complete football player i think is what
you called him you gotta love sauce
going in the top ten here right
oh i love it i want it for him so bad
come on man he's someone who's willing
to be a part of that that aggressive
blitz package but then he also will
cover it down and being able to cover it
down is important because if you're
gonna put pressure on someone if you're
gonna bring pressure you're gonna you
put yourself at risk you better have
somebody that can take care of it and
sauce is the guy that can take care of
it i love it the idea of my man from
cincinnati going in the top ten i
absolutely love it connor
all right well we promised on the show
we like the top 10 picks but we love
introducing you to the guys outside of
round one so we're going to look in the
third round for the giants here we're
picking 67. felder this week they cut
kyle rudolph evan ingram who was former
first rounder for them he's set to hit
free agency they got nothing at tight
end right now this is a tight end class
that there are going to be starters
there in round three i'm looking at the
long island bread and born ohio state
buckeye jeremy ruckert here for the
giants i think it gives them a little
bit more attitude in the trenches him
and a quantum together would be
something to watch but we've talked
about this before with rucker there's a
lot more on the table here as a pass
catcher how do you like his nfl fit and
projection i mean look at that catch
that's a catch against alabama with one
hand this is him finding the scene
against penn state we're watching look
at this look at this catch
in like come on in the in the big ten
championship game one hand he can catch
the football you see him there getting
loose in the middle against rutgers he
can catch the football and there's a
little run after catch for him that
makes him not just the catch and fall
down guy as some tight ends are so for
me i think there's real value you see
him there adjusting to the football i
think there's value i think he has he is
you mentioned it earlier i went with
devin pierce right i i think that this
is a guy who's also going to be better
in the nfl than he was in college
i think so too and i think that catch
radius in the renzo red zone can be a
young quarterback's best friend and we
know the giants are gonna need that for
daniel jones or whoever they bring in to
compete with him so rucker and there we
go we got a fan comment right there uh
aunt fabian says i love a1 sauce all
right loving the sauce pick moving on to
the washington commanders get you suit
folks the commanders no longer the
football team
felder this conversation is going to be
dominated by the quarterback debate in
the top 15. now you and i have gone on
the record probably not the year to be
looking to take one in the top 15. but
these are desperate times for the
commanders the veteran market is looking
a little questionable right now the
seahawks are saying they're not going to
trade russ we know if rogers leaves
green bay it's a good shot it's denver i
don't think derek carr is going to be on
the move the reality of this situation
is washington is going to have to deep
dive in this class most likely to find
their answer i'm going to throw the two
names at you because of how different
they are and because they're the two
most likely to go in the top 20 of this
draft you have kenny pickett from pitt
uh kenny gloves kenny two gloves at this
point malik willis high ceiling transfer
from auburn found a lot of success at
liberty let's start with picket felder
we've called him a high floor kind of
player
man how are you breaking down this
debate between the two for the
commanders
well i think it's a question of what you
want and i think we have to introduce
the the reality of
the careers right so we've got scott
turner as an offensive coordinator and
he's a guy obviously his dad's norv
turner so he's he's of that system and
they use traditional quarterbacks and
then you go into ron rivera's the head
coach and what happens with that oh um
he got to a super bowl with cam newton
also
maybe he got fired because cam newton
couldn't really play anymore because of
the injuries that happened when he was
getting abused by you know running and
and and the nfl not taking care of him
so you have to figure out where these
guys heads are but i think kenny pickett
is probably the pick that's the guy that
i sent in because he feels safer
again as we mentioned higher floor lower
ceiling higher floor he can throw the
ball fine he can do everything fine he
does understand he played for mark
whipple whipple is a guy that we know
has been an offensive coordinator in the
nfl multiple times at multiple stops
including with the steelers so that all
fits that all checks out malik willis
it's like going into the wild unknown of
what's going to happen at the next level
and
i listen i'll leave
malik willis to you because i know he's
your pick i i went with picket because
it felt safe but when we go to willis i
mean the traits are off the chart
yeah man this is floor versus ceiling it
comes down to that are the commanders
gonna go up to bat and take the home run
swing and you might strike out four out
of five times but if you hit that home
run in the league you can find yourself
a franchise passer that can carry you
into the postseason through the
postseason as we've seen for so many
years now whether it's joe burrow this
year mahomes allen on and on we go i
think what malik willis the breakdown is
this are you looking for somebody and
it's not just the running ability
although that is tremendous especially
in the red zone where you can really get
a defense off balance the vertical
passing is where malik willis is going
to really make his money and i think
washington has to decide are we going to
be patient or do we want somebody to
come in right now and be efficient
that's the high floor picking kenny
pickett or are we going to be patient
and try to develop a guy with malik
willis if you go out and trade a third
round pick for jimmy garoppolo and let
malik sit until he's ready that's an
option on the table for you you just
have to decide what offense you want to
be in you broke it down perfectly felder
history tells us this offensive staff
might prefer picket ron rivera has seen
the highs of a mobile vertical throwing
quarterback and he's also experienced
the lows although hopefully the league
now protects those guys a little bit
better than what cam newton went through
so commanders fascinating situation we
think it's going to be a quarterback i
know the comments have some varying
opinions
they are a team to watch to set the
tables of this draft and the quarterback
class
speaking of that the philadelphia eagles
three first-round picks in this draft
there is a lot to play with right here
felder and i know you are starting in
the trenches what are you looking at for
the eagles front four
listen fletcher cox
he's not young
so
i'm going devonta wyatt uh wyatt is
from georgia defensive tackle
i i think he's incredibly special he is
even in the sec championship game he's
someone that i mean you see him there
the effort that he's given it doesn't
all look pretty but he's getting it done
and i think that's important and that's
something that for me
i value i put value on seeing effort he
did the thing that jordan davis didn't
do in the sec championship game he
wanted to be on the field every single
play he found a way to be impactful
every single play
or as impactful as he could he wants to
make tackles and to me that does kind of
epitomize what you got out of
a fletcher cox right someone who's gonna
have an impact and so to me i look at
that i see that impact and i want more
of it and i'm going to try to get that
let's give me two years of this guy
with him and we've got we're in business
baby
i love it all right i'm going to stay
with the front seven and i like that he
brought up wide he's got a little bit
more pass rush and juice than his
teammate jordan davis i'm gonna look for
a front seven piece that never has to
come off the field and that's gotta be
devin lloyd from utah the eagles
traditionally under howie roseman do not
draft linebackers especially early
sometimes you got to make an exception
for a special player and i think that's
devin lloyd i think it's the instincts i
think it's the downhill speed as a
blitzer and you see the ability to make
plays on the ball and coverage and bring
it back to the house with that long
speed he's a little different than you
know in the kobe dean who's a smaller
guy devin lloyd is going to come in
around 6-2 6-3
run really really well come down in the
hole and make a hit so for the eagles
you're kind of restarting that
foundation in the trenches there right
felder you've got devonte wyatt you have
devin lloyd playing behind him this
would be a lot of fun for the
philadelphia defense
i i love it and you listen we always
talk about going a little deeper
i'm gonna go to to that day two day
three i'm going alec pierce
wide receipt like is he a wide receiver
or a titan like what would you what do
you think he's going to be at the next
level i guess is the first question
i would play him as a big slot i would
let him live in the slot and be a
mismatch against dbs or safeties and get
him in the ball i mean you see him on
the outside they're winning i don't know
how much he'll do of that the kyle at
the nfl level but felder i would like to
move him around and really use him as a
big slot target in the middle of the
field
yeah he's he's huge and
the big thing with him is he he the the
reason i asked that question is because
a lot of the catches that he makes a lot
of the plays that he makes they remind
me of jimmy graham
where he's not actually open
but because of his ball skills his uh
body control his his hand strength he's
able to make catches that he probably
shouldn't be making and so that's why i
asked do you ask him to gain some weight
and play tight end or do you want to
have him as a wide receiver i think that
big slot's really interesting because he
does draw a mismatch he's going to draw
a mismatch either way and then because
he's not going to run the fastest he is
still going to be a guy when you put him
on a safety or you put him on a
linebacker he's still going to have a
speed advantage there versus putting him
outside on the corner where he just has
that height advantage yeah i think with
that body type he can take the hits
across the middle of the field make that
transition and once again it goes back
to something we talk about on the show
all the time with so much wide zone
principles you need bigger bodied guys
out there that can make the blocks that
could sustain their blocks and open up
the running game so
a fun fun draft for the eagles we'll
sneak in a question here could david
jabo fall to philly from moose maxwell
felder what do you think of that i think
he could be on the board and we know
they need edge pass rush help still even
after re-signing josh sweat
yeah i mean he could i i'm still of the
mind of i don't know how good i think
that he is so i think he'll be there
i wonder about him playing without
aiden hutchinson and that's the question
for me about ajavo and there's no way to
prove that in in pre-draft workouts or
pre-draft the combine the whole deal so
you have to take a chance and if you
like his traits in terms of his speed
what he runs uh you know his strength
then i think he's i think i think he
will be there i don't think they're
there's they've run the risk of not
being able to get him i think the risk
comes in with how good do we what's his
ceiling look like without somebody
that's going to be an all-pro on the
other side of him
yeah that's a great point felder and i
think it's going to be a matter of with
the style of defense that they play are
they willing to
you know it's tough to call them a
liability against the run but it's
definitely a work in progress at the
moment for jabbo so that's how teams are
going to have to weigh the pass rush
juice with the speed on the edge versus
the containment against the run our last
team in the nfc east the dallas cowboys
always a popular favorite in the
bleacher report app i'll kick things off
here felder with a first round pick for
them kenyon green texas a m he's played
both tackle spots he's played both guard
spots i like him as a guard at the next
level and the cowboys have had a bit of
a revolving door at their left guard
spot and they're gonna take a little bit
of a hit there due to free agency as
well this is a line that needs to get a
little younger in some areas when you
look at a player that has the the
versatility to play all four spots in a
pinch just because he's maximized
talents at guard i think that off also
offers some value as well we know the
cowboys at their roots of their offense
are going to hand the ball to ezekiel
elliott you need those big maulers there
kenyon greenfelder
what do you think here this is a a
gardener in the first round is not
always the most popular selection but i
think he could be a difference maker in
dallas
yeah they're looking for listen the
reality of it is is everybody has
windows right you have these windows of
when you can get to a super bowl windows
of going to the playoffs and they're in
their window right now and
if they are missing a piece you go get
that piece it's better than going best
player available because you have a
thing that you have to fix and the thing
for me i flip it on the other on the
other side this isn't in the first round
i'm going a little bit later in the
draft but i am going to go with my jay
sanders and from cincinnati another i
love cincinnati if you guys can't tell
um i'm going with a pass rusher right we
know that they are obviously already
have mica parsons but i think you put
this guy on the outside as a pass rush
specialist now you have an opportunity
to be a real terror on third and long
and i do like his ability to play
against the run i think it's underrated
i think a lot of folks aren't giving him
credit for what he was asked to do
and he has this this there's a strength
to him there's an ability to to be
explosive so for me sanders is someone
look at the takeoff come on man the
takeoff right there can't beat that that
guy was that guy was still standing
there and he was already in the
backfield so i i look at all those
things i add them up and the big thing
that i'm looking at is let's add to this
pass rush so that our defense gets
better so that we help out because we
also on the if correct me if i'm wrong
but in the needs list they also have
cornerback and secondary as a needs list
you know what helps out a secondary get
into the quarterback pass rush
that's right felder i like that you
called out my j sanders ability to get
off the ball right when you look at the
teams that are gonna run
you know a lot of cover three and
they're gonna ask their front four to
get home right and those corners hold up
as you know you know a lot about that
they ask that front four to get home if
you just ask him to play on the outside
pin his ears back get off the ball
you're not asking him to sit and contain
you're not asking the two gap you're
just saying get up field get after the
quarterback we know maj sanders can do
that i love that pick in the second
round he's kind of been a slept on
player in a loaded pass rush group
before we close out let's get to some
comments from this i have to read this
just because it made me laugh from
thomas house that he said can the
cowboys draft a coach
i don't think we'll be doing the
coaching mock drafts on the show doc
woods asked linder bomb over green
question mark i think for me felder i
would be surprised if linderbaum is
still there when the cowboys pick uh i
would take him over green where do you
go with that conversation
yeah i'm on we're of the same mind i
mean that's there's a reason why linda
bomb was in our blue chip group that we
did a week ago exactly and green was not
so i mean i think we're pretty clear
that
we think he's an elite level center i
think the center spot is an interesting
one because every year it seems to slide
up and down up and down up and down in
terms of value but certainly i think
he's above green with respect to
where he fits in this ecosystem of
especially specifically interior
offensive lineman if we're looking at
green as a guard instead of looking at
him as a tackle
all right the next one from raylan hart
one who said dallas needs a big body
defensive tackle first and foremost
felder you already had devonta wyatt
coming off the board to the eagles i
think that eliminates him from the
equation but in this spot
jordan davis travis jones from uconn
i'll be honest here felder and i want to
know what you think of this
i think that's an area they can address
in round two of this trap i don't think
they need to take a d tackle in round
one
i think he might be able to get jordan
davis in round two if we're being quite
honest like
his value has slow has steadily declined
and not because he isn't good but
because people are looking for players
that are going to play x amount of snaps
and he's not going to do that so
it's going to be interesting to see how
it all fits i think that the reality is
there's a lot of good defensive tackles
in this draft there's just not a lot of
first-round defensive tackles in this
draft so it's a thing that they could
probably address a little bit later
yeah i'm with you this draft just
doesn't have that jeffrey simmons quinn
and williams kind of impact or ed oliver
obviously that was a loaded defensive
tackle class
it's not that kind of year before we get
out of here let's recap the uh a and the
nfc east breakdown here obviously have
the team needs on the board he picks for
all of these teams and some projected
fits felder liked equanu at five to the
giants and we i had sauce gardner there
at seven we both agree jeremy record at
67 can be a value tight end pick the
commanders the big debate for us there
is quarterback kenny pickett or malik
willis who is it going to be i think
that's what it's going to be down to the
eagles there three first round picks but
we gave you a little bit more davonte
wide and devin lloyd in round one felder
had alec pierce there
on day two of the draft and then the
cowboys get a little better up front on
both sides of the ball kenyan green to
plug and play guard maije sanders to
rush the passer
woo felder that was a long one running
back
preview day nfc east breakdown and next
week man we're gonna have some fun how
we feeling show two in the books
show two in the books and then we're
talking combine baby i know you're going
to indy we got a special guest coming up
next week three-person show we got a lot
to go like i'm excited man i'm having a
really good time doing this
yeah man it's been awesome as soon as i
take this mic off i am getting on the
plane going to the combine so next week
we will recap the combine we will have a
surprise guest and that'll be a trend
going forward with the show uh although
i i don't think anyone's sick of you and
i yet felder but we're gonna add a
little spice to the show so every
thursday 1 p.m eastern time here in the
bleacher report app tap in to draft
crash course we will catch you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you